[Music]
we will
kick off with apologies are there any
apologies
conflicts of interest
any conflicts
confirmation of minutes somebody
prepared to move 3.1
with council blackie seconded
councillor williams put it always in
favor please say aye
carried 3.2 any matters of rising from
the minutes
appear to be none i haven't been told of
any deputations presentations so we go
straight into reports
5.1
joanne
so
um
[Music]
thank you
um this report is uh following a request
for further information which was
requested
at the council's annual plan meetings um
to provide some
information around
rating impacts and potential timing for
this pro these projects
at this stage
these two projects haven't been included
in the annual plan and the reasoning for
this was
to allow a council to consider this
against other projects
around the district as part of the
long-term plan
the rating impacts if it was to be
included next year are summarized under
item 1.2
so 0.5 of a percent against the rate
roading rate and 0.1 against the general
rate
there's two sets of recommendations that
have been provided
the first is to either decline and note
that it would be considered as part of
the long-term plan or the alternate is
to place a recommendation to council
just leave it at that and happy to take
any questions
we've got questions councillor whitman
uh thank you joanne in
paragraph 4.2
it says there is current budget no
budget allocated for this project
could you just clarify i'm assuming
there's no budget yeah my apologies that
should read there is currently no budget
allocated for this project
any further questions
council williams
i'd like to move a d and a
so you're
wanting them in for the end this year's
annual plan consideration
somebody prepared a second
is
so the original elapsed because of one
of seconder
i think councillor gordon has moved a b
and c seconded by councillor blackie
i'm not opposed to this work being
considered but it's just out of
context we've just been through our
annual plan
and i think that to look at this we need
to look at it in its complete picture
so i think it should come through
as further consideration of our
long-term plan but if we want to bring
that metaphor that's a matter we can
consider at any time but i just don't
think putting it in right at the moment
is the right answer
when we've just been through a holistic
process it's looked at our whole budgets
you know another eight hundred and five
thousand would uh would add a
well another point one percent increase
and until we see the complete picture of
where we end up i don't think it's
sensible just adding it in it's
so i think the recommended path is the
right one and if we want to consider it
sooner we can consider that as part of
the
2022-23 annual plan
council blackie yep you can agree it's
all about priority
[Music]
anybody else
council williams
yeah i'd be opposing that because um
it's actually the community board that
has been talking about this for years
and years and years
before i've i've even been on council
wanting um particularly past the amp
showgrounds getting
new
turbine channel and crosstail it's an
entrance way to the whole of the town
like um
every every council here was normally
wanting entrance ways to the town
as a community board recommendation and
so that's why i can't support not
going ahead with it i would have been
quite happy
with an amendment going just in front of
the amp show grounds which was basically
half of it without going down cold
stream road but
the main thing is to get the image
and culturing road is a uh sorry not
cold from rome but ashley street is a
main entrance way to rangera with the uh
um
the amp show grounds here which is a
feature area and
the long grass and everything actually
looks really really bad there so
i think it's an important thing to need
to be done
anybody else
just briefly myself
i don't see myself so much going against
the the community would i've got
absolutely no doubt this work will be
done
but i do agree with mia as far as
priorities are concerned just at the
present point and i'll be very happy to
argue that in front of the community
board and members of the uh
of the community
um yeah it's all about timing with
regard to this
um there's some areas that i i don't
know what's going to develop uh in the
future over the road
um so yeah
i see putting it off
for a discussion in a year and a year
and a half's time i don't see that as
particularly biggie so that's my two
cents with it
anybody else
council duty
i actually agree with councillor
williams that is that part of you it
looks so untidy
um and
i appreciate that
it is quite a substantial amount of
money but
in the
whole range of the area i think it's
important to continue on with that
beautification along that road and and
down to crime's cold stream road it
needs it's important
council
yeah look i have sympathy with council
williams's
view as well i i think that um attending
shows there and and doing the things
that you do do at the amp showground i
think it's quite a disgrace that it's in
the condition that it's in um and it's
not looked after well
and i think that it's absolutely
important that
all of a sudden on one particular day of
the year you get thousands of people and
then six weeks later you get another
thousands of people and then the rest of
the time it sees
not many people
but um
you talk about priorities i think
looking after places that have thousands
of people that conglomerate there in a
very quick time
is actually something that we should
take
um a great pride in
and i think that particular area around
both of those streets is particularly
poor served
poorly surfed sorry poor served
any others
mr reply
just to say i i don't disagree with the
sentiments of the project being done um
and the work being done and perhaps
there's other ways that this can be
considered in the interim
the durian team can consider which is
including partnering with the amp
around the maintenance of that area and
beautifying that because it is at times
i live in that area too i see what
condition it's in so maybe that's
something we our team could be having a
conversation uh with the uh our
maintenance contractor about
in in partnership with the amp
but everything needs to be considered in
context and that's the thing that really
was the bit for me and it's not against
the community board at all in fact
unlike council brian i'm really happy to
go and have that conversation with the
board submission on that it's a matter
where we can consider in the context of
that
as well it's not opposed to the board
but it's just everything's about
prioritization and work so
let's see those things come back but
jared i would welcome you and joanne
looking at the maintenance along there
and whether that can be added in because
a simple mow along there
around the corner and some maintenance
would make a big difference in the
interim but let's look at the wider
project in the context of other matters
that we'd like to see addressed
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say hi all right against
i want to record it
we'll move on to 5.2 scubage
hi everyone my name is jake for those of
you that don't know me
i'm just here to talk about skewbridge
this report is for information only
and it's regarding our project
to install active warning signs on
skewbridge
this is this project is planned to be a
bit of a temporary measure while we look
at
the potential upgrade of skewbridge in
the future
so the project is estimated to cost
approximately
285 thousand dollars and we've currently
got a budget with 51 funding from waka
katahi of 330 000.
um we're planning on
proceeding to detailed design after this
meeting and
engaging with manpower directly for the
power supply works of the actual warning
sign and undertaking an open tender for
the rest of the civil works associated
with the with the installation
um
then that's that's about it is there any
questions
council award
i'll work my way around
thank you um just a little query when
you're talking to main power and
for the
getting the electricity and the
down for the lights
would it be prudent to also make sure
there's enough there to accommodate for
when we do the screw bridge the new
screw bridge any any requirements that
we might need for the bigger the bigger
picture so we only do it once
that's it's a good question the i think
the only area where we would potentially
look to require
um power on the bridge itself would be
to if we were actually thinking about
putting street lighting over the bridge
um or if we were to include some sort of
cycle facility and wanted lighting for
that
um
it's certainly something we can just
cover off with them and see
whether in the future that could be
extended if it was required
but i guess as a comparison
the cones road the ashley river bridge
we haven't got any street lighting or
pedestrian lighting on that at the
moment
that one again there was provision in
the future if we ever got to that point
but it's not a level of service we would
currently be looking to provide unless
there was a dedicated facility there
that required it
but yes in short so we can um just make
sure there is the um ability to be able
to extend that in the future if it was
needed
williams
yeah this amount is just for active
warning signs that correct can you tell
me the difference between the cost of
the normal ones you put down slow down
ones and all that with the solar panels
there
there's a humongous difference between
that and this budget here
what's what's the big difference so this
is a little more than just signage
this also includes
some thresholds
some changes to the road marking
some
tactile indicators to make sure we're
trying to keep people in their lanes
so it extends beyond just the signs the
other thing with this one is we've
worked been working well jig's been
working with the science supplier
and because of the number of vehicles
going through the site and the day
the
solar panels
wouldn't hold enough charge to keep the
signs working so that's why it requires
a permanent power supply which is more
expensive
just that
they've got these type of signs in the
honduras on solar powers and
they seem to act 24 hours seven days a
week and
with the battery scenario so what would
be the difference of that
i would imagine there'd be more traffic
and the honda leaves going from picking
to
christchurch both ways then um the sku
bridge would have so i'm a wee bit
amused by needing power that's all
um i can't comment on how many vehicles
go through the handles i honestly don't
know that figure off the top of my head
but jake's done a lot of work with the
science supplier and that's certainly
their recommendation um that it is a
permanent supply and that was included
in the report
i can probably add to that a little bit
there are other types of batteries that
we could use there's lithium batteries
for example the ones that are in
electric cars um they generally store
more power there's a wee bit of a
downside to them which is the the heat
element so and in conditions under
zero degrees celsius lithium batteries
don't do so well so they they don't
retain charge and so they don't they
don't charge themselves and zero degrees
or less which would make it a bit
difficult on frosty mornings if if we
had one too many frosty mornings that it
couldn't charge itself
i i am an electrician and i understand
that but yeah i was trying to compare
with we could probably get bigger frosts
and the hunger leaves
compared with in the school bridge here
that's just i was trying to figure out
the difference
councillor blackie
my questions jacob following on from
paul um
for two questions what what
in in your cost of 285
do you can you tell us what main powers
part of supplying permanent power is to
that i don't think that's in the report
or did i miss it and
getting back to the lithium battery
thing um okay if they won't charge below
zero why can't they be insulated why
can't you have your lithium battery in
an insulated box so it doesn't drop
below zero
um in terms of the main power element
what we are hoping to do is
if they are doing any trenching for the
power supply ducts so that would be the
pipe where the lines go through that
would be done underneath the main tender
so the the element of it would just be
connecting the wires from one point to
another through the pipes and just
connecting it up
in terms of
cost we have not obtained a cost
estimate from main power yet we're still
waiting for their feedback to provide
that that cost and that'll largely be
dependent on the electrical design that
they come up with
in terms of the lithium battery i'm i'm
not too sure so i could go back to the
supplier and ask them some of these
questions um in regards to the battery
is there something else that we could do
but from there um from what what they
were telling me they advised that
permanent power supply would probably be
the best option in this location
saying is that the the power's there
they're only they've only really got to
hook it up
they're not going to charge us megabucks
to run power from sifton to there like
they usually do um so so we can assume
their bill their their bill will be
a minor part of the of the cost is that
what you're saying
um
it depends what you're doing there is
some trenching required um so what jig
is saying is that it's been allowed for
as part of the construction contract and
because there isn't power right the way
through there um so there is a little
bit from i think from mill road
at ohoka the rehearker road end
to
where the signs are located which is
kind of along that straight heading into
a sku bridge and also equivalent at the
other end so there is definitely
trenching required to extend the power
to that point
um so that is part of it yeah
okay so let's do it
thank you
um you mentioned
some sort of laning for cyclists is that
part of this
um this bit of work directing cyclists
somewhere across skewbridge
or is the part of the grander design
so it's mentioned in the report in terms
of the thresholds where the signs are
going to go and just making sure
this space on the shoulder that a
cyclist can get through because we know
that cyclists use that route we see them
on sku bridge
but there won't there won't be a way of
providing
facilities on the bridge for them as
part of this work so we're just making
sure that any infrastructure that does
go in doesn't use up that shoulder
that's currently there that they do use
because i draw your attention to
skewbridge lane
which goes across
um it's on page 26
it's a paper road that goes right across
the line side road
and
to my mind if there's
there's a greater design here you need
to get the cyclists off there
and and and re well
make good
that walking cycling link that goes
through which is
you've seen see on page
26 of the report where you've got your
yellow bit of skewbridge
uh to the what's that north
uh the lane the well the road that goes
straight across and links around that's
a lane
which is
used by walkers and cyclists and and
to my mind needs to be incorporated as
an access
way
as part of the
overall design
and certainly acknowledge
it in in whatever work you you're
potentially doing with directing
cyclists
at this early stage
so i guess the question sort of there is
are you looking at
incorporating any of this work to
facilitate cyclists using skubridge lane
so it's
apologies skewbridge lane i'm struggling
to see where it is but so is that across
the river
i'm assuming it runs along the side of
the of the river
driveway
i think that driveway is
um
i'm thinking this is going to be a
project for an another time
i was going to say i think that's
potentially part of the network plan
but then also part of the
longer term what do we want to do with
sku bridge what facilities do we provide
if when we replace it and how that gets
incorporated in the wider network
picture
because we've also got the cycle way
that pops out
from what was the old island road um
down opposite mill road and even with
that one it's how do we connect that in
the future through
to the passchendaele pass
councillor duty
just uh two questions please can you
just explain please the ceramic domes
what are those
um ceramic domes are so they have them
um inside certain locations in
christchurch they are
similar to those raised reflective
pavers that you see on the roads but
they're just white domes that get stuck
on the ground in a similar way what we
expect them to do is when a car drives
over them you generally hear
so um it just alerts them
gives them an audio alert that they are
crossing over onto the other lane
next question please is this um
signage that's for that slow down one is
that similar to the one you put in um
at um
tram road is that similar to that let's
slow down one
um yes it is slightly different that's
for the intersection where this will
have a curve
but it's the same sort of process yep so
as the car is coming up to it it will
activate and it will flash
warning and reminding people to slow
down yeah
this is
uh i guess two curves where we just
continue to have people fall off the
road and i think speed is a part of that
well that that i will say that the
electronic warning sign is excellent
so um
i'd be all for seeing that happen down
there
well i'll test the meeting by moving
assuming there's no further questions
moving a b c d
e to read
after after further investigation on
batteries
procurement is proposed etc
second and councillor council of
williams um just very very briefly uh
this is essential it's not the work that
we want make no mistake we all know that
around the table um in my pre-briefing
with mr matured yesterday you know i
raised again
any possibility that
nzta are going to come to the ball and
we can get it done properly the answer
is no so we have to make it as safe as
we as we possibly
possibly can
this is a step along the way of making
it as safe as possible as we can
with the um
without nzta and the big scheme well
noting that they're still paying 51
and i picked up the points would we get
ready to go to batteries i think there
was a wee question there
could
you know so i'll throw it in if
it's workable it's workable if it's not
you fall back to
main power
mr man
oh sorry counselor williams no i fully
support this project i think it's um
important to be done
being an electrician i am concerned i
think the battery option would be a lot
cheaper to do because um
obviously you haven't had a price for
main power yet and
i roughly know what that cost would be
to go from that side of the bridge under
the bridge all the way there in a
neutral screen table
i don't know whether there's a
transformer there that
we don't have to supply transform to get
um to 230 volts from the um high tension
cables as well i presume there's
230 volts here but
um it seems to me that for my
knowledge around looking at um a lot of
these road signs most of them
are battery powered and seem to be
lasting no problem at all
the the battery situation can be um
insulated and i believe the one and the
honda lease is still running wet cell
batteries and that's been there for
years and years and years and um
yeah so exploring the the battery
scenario is in my box quite important
thank you
just briefly fully support this this has
been a piece of work we've been
considering for some time
obviously skewbridge having the bridge
replaced uh is our ideal objective but
in the interim we do need to address the
safety issues along
this particular corridor look if there's
opportunities to save money in a better
option with battery then i'm open-minded
to that and i support the
proposed weeding because i think it
gives that scope but um thank you to
staff for the work that they've done on
this because there'll be a lot of people
very appreciative of these warning signs
here as an interim step until we get um
hopefully a bridge replacement which we
haven't given up on so uh thank you um
uh jig and joanne for your work on this
any further
council ward
this is just a question
about the screw bridge and nzta
have we
i know there's a lot of accidents out
that aren't reported that you know
happen
um have we got the farmers taking photos
of any incidents so that we have got a
recording of incidents and accidents
that aren't necessarily reported through
injury so that we can forward our case
for the new bridge
um yes and the residents down there are
very active in terms of providing us
with that information which is really
good because it does help us build a
picture
to be honest we've been very very lucky
that to date the accidents i saw crashes
that have occurred
have generally been minor
and haven't been a serious
or fatality
the reality is i think that's more good
luck than good management and as traffic
volumes increase along that corridor the
risk increases
and we are
going to do some work to
look at
some risk profiling to see if that can
help us forward our case
for replacement of the bridge
but unfortunately the way in cta or
kotahi funding is
set
it often does rely on deaths and serious
injuries as the main driver for
financial
um
or money going into a specific project
so we just don't have that crash history
of serious infertilities there
councillor atkinson well look i just
actually have a question for me mr mr
chair just around the deaths i know of a
young man who spent uh 14 months in jail
after killing his passenger on that
bridge
um and i know of another death that was
also on that bridge and there they are
some time ago i'll give you that
but do we not carry those statistics
forward and just supplement that
question
these signs i would imagine
when when we get it fixed or think
positively
are relocatable to somewhere else is it
um so
yes and yes yes there are fatalities
that have happened at their site but
they are beyond 10 years which is
normally the time frame their nzta used
for what kotahi use for assessing
that as part of a project and yes we
would absolutely be able to use them
elsewhere afterwards
nothing further
i'm not going to use my right of reply
i'll put it all those favorably say i
against kerry
on to 5.3
hi everyone um another report here for
you today this one's in regards to the
wastewater treatment plant fencing
upgrade contract
this was a contract that was completed
um some time ago
in 2020 during covert there was some
questions in regards to the contract and
how that went so i thought i'd
update you on that contract
so the contract was awarded to joe
redwood fencing for the tinder price of
440 dollars this day were programmed to
be completed by the 11th of may 2020.
unfortunately due to covert the the
march lockdown they actually had quite a
few delays the first being the level 4
lockdown and then second being a few
supply chain delays as a result of the
lockdown and
shortage of steel
for the fencing wire however they did
manage to complete the works
in
prior to
the financial end of the 2020 financial
year so by june 2020
the project overall was completed with 7
700 worth of variations so very minor um
and
it's it's worth noting that the overall
project expenditure was
below the budget which was
162 thousand dollars four hundred
dollars overall for all the different
sites and locations um included in here
is a couple of the photos of the
different sites and um the work that
would the work we did which was
installation of barbed wire on the top
and bottom of the existing deer fence
and at the rangiora wastewater treatment
plant we upgraded the stock fence the
short stock fence to the higher x fence
and installed barbed wire along the top
and bottom of that fence as well as the
existing defense at the site
thank you very much
we've got questions
nope somebody prepared to
move council blacky seconded
council williams
thank you i remember sitting around here
when this was first brought to us years
ago and the price was 250
000 to do this and we all threw up our
hands in horror and said to the staff no
no no go away and rethink this so very
very comforted to see it come in at 80
well done
yes williams
no i think we've um got what we've asked
for and um it's just basically um
referring to the community board of what
we've done i think
anybody else
no reply i'll put it almost favorably
say aye
against carried
go onto
six which is correspondence and i have
none
go on to 7.1
report from community board
wanting us to approve
i'm thinking i was going to talk to this
one on shane's behalf um so this
has been taken to
the woody and septon community board and
it's a request to install no stopping on
warn street
in sefton
israel
the carriageway through the area has
been sealed adjacent to the new
development and kuben channel installed
you'll see from the photos
the
carriageway is quite constrained when
vehicles are parking along next to the
kerbin channel
at the moment there's construction of
houses being undertaken
and residents are having issues getting
through their area so we are asking
for approval to install some no stopping
to help ensure that
residents can access through that area
i'm happy to take any questions
council ribbon
uh thank you joanne
is recommendation c the updated
recommendation
when this came to the wooden sefton
community board there was
some discussion that there hadn't been
any consultation with the
four property owners that will be
affected by this
and my recollection is c
was altered slightly to provide for some
engagement i think was the word used
before this went further
could i just ask where is it where is
sean
a summary
in the actual report it's a b and c so a
is receives the report
um
and then in the um
so that was the wooden shift and
community board resolution so
i suspect what's happened when it gets
transferred
yeah
yeah so the a has been lost off the
recommendation because that was a
recommendation to the utilism writing
committee so um
that is the reference to b is as per the
um
agenda for the unr committee so it does
talk to the same
point
so have you got a follow-up question as
a result of that
yes um
i think the c that i was referring to on
page 69 must now be b
so my question is has bee been updated
following the wooden sefton
community board meeting
i'm not sure whether you can help me
with this one adrian but i don't know
whether it will have been within the
report
but it does note that we um
would be talking to the residents before
any work was done so this is for an
approval and principle for the
installation of the no stopping
and just it's probably worth adding when
this came through management team i
spoke specifically to shane about making
sure that we were proactive and doing
that prior to the implementation so you
can take it from us that this won't
happen before
we've had um that notification to those
residents and give them an opportunity
to give feedback
[Music]
mr mayor and then councilwoman so this
is it proposing because i know there was
some concern around the hedge what is
what will happen to the hedge if this is
approved
um so nothing at this point so um one
one of the um
we did seek advice from the
reserves people um
and it's not possible to cut the hedge
right back adequately without destroying
it
in the longer term so
there are would be options such as
potentially
starting to establish a hedge further
back from the boundary and allowing this
to be ultimately removed
but that wouldn't be able to happen in
time
for resolving this issue before
residents start moving into these houses
and we start to have issues in the
street so that would be more of a
long-term option so
um certainly if it becomes a problem for
residents in the future there still is a
way that the council can
address that over time so so what's the
urgency of this being addressed before
we undertake that consultation or having
it approved because
you know would it not just
be more sensible for this to lay on the
table and await
that consultation to occur and then
bring that feedback back for resolution
just just posing as a question
there isn't a lot of there aren't a lot
of alternative options in this situation
so
if
and also given that these are just
really under construction
um often it is better to get on ahead of
these things earlier so there would be
some risk in allowing people to
establish patterns of parking on the
street at the moment it's builders
on the street but
then this almost starts to set more of
an expectation that that will be
available whereas there's just not
physical room on the road to allow
on-street parking
[Music]
castle williams
my concern is similar
if the four properties didn't want it to
happen would it actually happen or would
you come back to us first
because consultation with them doesn't
mean
if they didn't want it to happen we'd
try and resolve that with them and if we
couldn't we bring it back to you yes
cool
council ribbon
uh thank you the woody and zefton
community board were happy with the
recommendation
there aren't many alternatives and it is
a very narrow road the four houses are
either under construction i'm not sure
if anyone has moved into one of them yet
or not
it'll be pretty close so they're
probably as europe indicated
a benefit in doing it now before you end
up with four residents who may have
contrary views
my point is really that the b
should reflect
what the wooden theft and community
board was actually recommending and
my recollection is the word engagement
was tossed in
it wasn't saying there had to be a full
consultation
i was going to get you to move something
but you're not actually no no i'm not a
member so thank you for that
clarification and yeah i i just wondered
mr chair whether governance could be
asked for a copy of the minutes from the
wooden theft and community board so you
pass
hopefully the recommendation that they
were approving
i'll call for a brief adjournment to
find out what those minutes yeah well
another one more question yet thank you
just a clarification please on this
hedge
which prevailing when does it does it
stop
we do propose to leave the hedge
and
we wouldn't remove it without having
given that careful consideration that's
um you know might be
planting a secondary hedge yeah yeah you
just try and get that established prior
so this does not propose to remove that
no no but just from the point of view of
a resident i'd be very happy to see that
there if it stops prevailing winds
annoyingly
so
just to move things along here
councillor redmond
because i wasn't at that meeting
i i can't see
a heck of a lot of difference between
what's in front of us
and the report that went to the
community board
so
do you think i would be safe getting a
member of the committee to move
what is in 7.1 on the order paper for
today
do you think that reflects the community
board's intention
[Music]
i think it does at the community board
that
be was amended slightly
to provide for engagement with the
existing owner or owners before the work
was carried out
so it's very close but it
the wording was altered at that meeting
we have got an insurance assurance that
there will be engagement so
are you prepared to move
right so moved councillor williams
seconded councillor blacky council
williams yeah i think it's a sensible
thing to do and we have got an insurance
here if the people do
not want it or going to come back to
this committee so that really covers the
um other community board's concerns
as well so
it's working
engagement there is in in is in there
under under a so so i'm not quite sure
what phil's
um perturbed about there we have got
subject to engagement in um
anybody
else reluctant to support this without
knowing what the community's opinion is
um i don't like removing trees or seeing
trees removed particularly one is with
such an established boundary
as this here is and that is the ultimate
consequence of this
uh recommendation so
um
appreciate the root words engagement i
don't see there's engagement in the end
so let's see where that comes to but i
take the assurance of mr cleary that if
there is strong views
that that will be brought back also the
thing to consider is the sporting groups
which use this reserve which are
actually quite substantial
and that's the location preferred
location for the new community facility
so i do have a lot of
reservations about this as a consequence
of that i appreciate developments
happened along there and we've been
pushed to make sure that this
development occurs but i i have a lot of
reservations about this direction of
travel and i did express it at the time
of management so
to be perfectly honest i'm not in favor
of voting for that so
if i could just clarify
resolution a
as it is in the um agenda on your page
four
i believe is as per the um
community board
so sorry about the confusion um the
report itself is the original report
that went to the community board it has
been edited
so resolution a
recommendation a says approves in
principle the installation of the
following non-stop and restriction on
vaughn street subject to engagement with
the residents
so i believe that has captured what was
being looked for by the community board
this
resolution
also would see the retention of the
trees so this is the yeast correct this
is because um it does not actually seek
approval to remove the trees it's to put
in the no stopping restriction which
will enable the trees to remain so i
apologize my question for i i had
undertook i had thought that that was
the ultimate result was the removal of
the trees so if that's not the case then
i'll vote in favor of it thank you
council reuben
yes uh just to apologize for the
confusion i was going on the main report
um i think your item seven and the
summary agenda uh reflects what was
agreed at the the community board
meeting and certainly it does see the
retention of the hedge so it's just the
no parking
lines
any reply
you know that's what i thought i was
moving with just the no stopping signs
in nothing to do with the hedge
very good i'll put it all those in favor
please say aye all right okay
scary so we've got a number of matters
for information as somebody prepared 8.1
through to 8.6
move council blacky seconded
myself
no discussion on the matters so i'll put
it all those in favor please say aye
against
carried go on to nine
uh 9.1
writing councillor williams
would you allow me to go through
go to council stuart i know she's very
prepared i was talking about it earlier
flat out
okay um
i think we're going to have an update
anyway about service requests following
the flooding there's 500 service
requests
covering the may december and february
flooding
we've got a new flood team
of two external
people
working four days a week each to triage
these
service requests
and kelly
simpson tells me that he expects about
detailed investigations to come out of
these 500 service requests so there's
quite a body of work there
a bit of a heads up
we have um private
property owners on private water
supplies along wood end
rangioral road whose wells
are now
reading contamination with
arsenic
manganese and iron over the maximum
allowable value
i they've
they've spoken to some staff and they
asked me to
ask staff
there's half a dozen of them at the
moment wanting to connect in
in a restricted supply to the council's
public supply i've had a talk with um
with kelly and um
and urged that when
detailed costings are now being worked
on
rather than just deal with the half
dozen to extend it wider because what's
happening with these wells and they
point the finger at ravenswood
and the excavations that's happened um
they're right next door to ravenswood
um and
council staff are looking to see that
ravens would consent to see whether
there is any condition in there that
protects
um the
neighbouring private wells
that's sort of ongoing as as i speak
but
extending the consultation once there's
some costings here
to to go further along run your wood end
road if these wells are turning they're
going anoxic which is low oxygen
and you get the release of
arsenic and the other minerals from the
rock
um if these wells are
turning rogue so will others people
don't know that because they don't test
so my um
i was really keen that as i said once um
once there's some costings that it goes
out further than just these half dozen
um
rangiora rural drainage issue last week
we had um
mount sea stream where we've had quite a
um
quite a lot of
yeah it was oxford last week no you said
rangiora did i yeah i thought i said oh
oxford sorry rural drainage issue
um mountain stream um the um
it was brought up that neighbours have
lost
10 metres out of their paddock the the
culvert has been ripped out um and this
follows
vegetation about 20 hectares then
cleared for forestry up the hill and
this was done last year
the landowner got in touch with ecan to
no real avail and he's saying now
there's 1500 meters of
gravel six foot deep in mountain stream
as a result of the um
the rain hitting this very steep
hillside um the council is responsible
does work in mountain stream itself and
drains going into it
so
it's been drawn attention to ecan again
and i've also asked
planners our planners whether there is
any provision for what happens when when
a landowner takes
50 acres of
cover off a steep hillside and this is
what happens down below it
so that's ongoing kevin mertens who
chairs the oxford rural drainage
advisory group expressed his
disappointment
with the fact that we're now
rather than
as you know cycon now contracts to do
the rural drainage
areas and
they were these groups were of farmers
who know the areas as you well
would understand like in the back of
their hand were promised improvements
about the way work was programmed and
kevin told the group last week that he
did not see the promised improvement
being realised so i'm just
passing that on
stuart councillor williams
um
in february the rain event caused a lot
of surface flooding and damaged unsealed
roads around the district there are
three
um currently graders doing the um
the roads
my big concern was with the roads was at
the community board level it was raised
about the the gravel roads are
quite
a pittance um
around the districts and this is before
the the flood arrangement we had there
and um
[Music]
that was
actually raised before i got the chance
to raise it because it was one wide
thoughts i was going to raise at the
community board i've had assurance from
joanne that
we've actually got the level of
top course on the on the road so it just
seems to be a maintenance grading
scenario and i'm very concerned because
as a counselor on the portfolio of
roading i've never had so many
complaints about the condition of our
gravel roads in the district ever and
it's just mounting up and it's not just
coming from the public it's coming from
the community board members as well as
other couple of other councillors here
that's been
bringing on about the road so
i have got concerns of
the level of service we're getting with
grading our roads that's happening
around the community so that's just
something that's going on and i think
personally needs to be addressed a bit
harder than what has been happening
um
uh we've got a butcher's road fold arch
culvert um
i went and had inspector there the
actual culvert it's actually still
okay it's um to me it looks like the
flood waters
uh has washed away the gravel proceeding
to the culvert there so i don't think it
could be called a culvert um
fail as such it's the um
um i've actually tried to get down to
have a look into it the culvert's got
quite a lot of um
crud in the bottom of it which probably
has hindered the flow of the water
through so
that's a wee bit of
a problem in the in the maintenance game
of um
some of the drains is actually affecting
some of our road work as well
so it's um
um yeah so that's the culvert scenario
um
the work has been replacing the failed
pip arch culvert and
glen road
that's really about it apart from the
works continuing on the resell program
with
approximately 60 done on ship seal sites
complete and 80 of the asphalt sites
complete
thank you we'll go straight on to you
again
yeah um
the water
and sewerage we've
we've had a few complaints on the um
kaipoy
plant with a lot of sludge build-up and
smells for the
neighborhood that happened all around
the the christmas time
um
the staff have been very good um
putting some chemical around trying to
eliminate the smell and
and what have you but it's um
there is a toxic algae in the
ponds at the moment which we're probably
going to have to address some here so um
hopefully we can get a report one day to
um to see the the problems we've um
going to be faced there the good thing
is this year we haven't had the botulism
with the birds this year that's
i think you can count the number birds
on one hand so
which is a real good
advantage and um having thousands see
that previous happened which seems a
little funny because it's been a hot
year um compared with other years
yeah so that's that's been pretty good
um
on the water side um there's a wee bit
of concern about the escalating costs
the prices of the materials and getting
workers to do it so and that's been
brought up by um all of us pretty much
on budgets and what have you but
it seems to be um
getting out of hand there uh cost
rapture
had a not not nothing to their council
but it's actual our contractors in the
supply of the
gods and bits and pieces seem to be an
ongoing problem so
that's about it for me all right thank
you so we'll roll on to on to myself
so the joint
committee's meeting in christchurch on
the 4th of april i haven't got an agenda
set out sent out yet
so that would be a meeting
to look forward to
of particular interest in this portfolio
is
the inaugural meeting that occurred
yesterday of the wdc solid waste
services governance
group
this was
chaired by don young
attendees obviously myself greg
slaughter from waste management jaco
klonums from waste management
craig downey from eco central uh jared
kitty monis and obviously don who was
was cheering it
um so some prep work had gone into it
including a potential
draft terms of of reference
so it's
in essence the the draft terms of
reference there's going to be two groups
now after
some discussion uh it was decided to
have a more operational
uh governance group that would meet
initially monthly
hopefully extending out to quarterly and
then a more bigger picture
governance group that will meet
quarterly as far as the operational side
is is concerned
i won't be
attending
it's not so much day-to-day things but
there are certainly things that
that kitty jared and bernice need to
deal with as far as waste management is
concerned and they don't need my
interference in doing that
it was a very good meeting on discussing
uh ways forward and ways that we can
better work together
you know some of the big picture you
know you've heard me discuss a better
utilization of of levy and what have you
and certainly craig from eco central uh
he's researching ideas from around the
country and from from overseas so
potentially
although we're two-thirds through the
term
something might come up before the end
of the term that i can hang my hat on as
far as a big project is concerned but i
was quite excited by that uh that
meeting
uh yesterday and i think it signals a
good way forward as far as our council's
working relationship
um
just a tiny heads up uh saying we're all
giving a sort of heads up um
covert and and waste obviously waste
being an essential service
it's already been mentioned as far as
staff is concerned
but but drivers
how are we going to keep our transfer
stations uh open if there is an outbreak
greg has been looking at these scenarios
and trying to predict how he can
best keep our service
in operation
but as you will anticipate over the next
couple of months
those who are tasked with those jobs are
going to be facing some very serious
challenges and
and i guess i'm sort of
you're going to hear about some of those
challenges you're going to get phone
calls from people if
their bin is not collected on the day
it's supposed to be and some of you will
have seen the stuff
item in today's newspaper
it's going to be challenging for those
who are tasked they're going to give it
the best effort
and i just hope that if you forward any
queries through the staff you appreciate
that it's not staff's fault
they're doing the best that they can
so that's uh that's my uh update so
we're going to transport
you can ask a question on
on yours what's going on anyway
um i noticed on sunday there's great big
queues of cars at the transfer station
is there any way we can look at
alleviating that even on existing ones
at the moment i know that we've got um
spacings and all that drama but the
it's an outdoor area
and people are unloading and loading
their own stuff
so jared had a and i don't want to go
too much into the operational side of
things but certainly jared raised a few
questions very good questions yesterday
and these are things that uh that waste
management have given an undertaking
that they will
they are the type of things jarrod had
quite a wee list of of things and as i
said i don't want to go into it today
because we haven't got answers to all of
them and and yeah i don't know if you
want to add anything more
um
yeah certainly uh the key
some of the key issues that have been
coming up via fire
members of public elected members we've
raced those
just in terms of the operation at the
transfer station
the lanes are
open now without the same physical
distancing at the refuse pit
so
and i am conscious
that
we do have long-term upgrades planned
for the site
and we really are starting to get to the
limits of its capacity
so
some of them we can manage through
trying to improve the operations on site
but you're quite right to raise these
and these are parts you know you have
got some funding in the long term plan
to allow for some of those capacity
upgrades
but yeah certainly i see this
initiative where we've got that
governance group up and going will be a
good forum for some of these things to
be managed in a much more formal manner
and
certainly aware of those issues
[Music]
just me
i've just been a little jubilant over
here um dunedin's just bought and joined
communities for local democracy
it's one of my more interesting
presentations i've been through today
that eight how was it eight seven
so
anyway so that's a really good result
from that perspective but back to
transport um
region um lot been going on at a
regional level um
there's been discussions happening with
environment canterbury last week with
respect to the opposition regarding rail
and patient derail they had a notice of
motion that we then went through the
regional transport committee it's fair
to say that
um that matter hadn't been socialized
amongst partners prior to that and so
from our perspective where it landed
which was a further report was the right
move and that we we understand where
all these pressures are going well all
these work streams are going to come
from because at a greater christchurch
level we've got the mass rapid transit
work underway
there's also then been an increase a
request to from other councils around
passenger transport
um so there's just a lot of work streams
and ambition around transport that you
know we all share to a degree but we've
just got to be
realistic about what can be achieved i'm
not opposed to rail as an option but all
the figures we've seen to date it just
doesn't stack as an option
further investment and passion to
transport
and the infrastructure around that may
well be the answer so there's a meeting
now being set up with the minister for
the end of
march uh which we've been invited to be
part of and it's really important as
part of that that we have a joined up
um position
so that the minister gets clarity about
what is the priority for canterbury i've
been a bit concerned about where these
work streams have been coming from
individual notice of motions that have
been coming which then set us off on a
different work potentially different
work streams so
there is finally i think starting to
become some realism that we just can't
expect
all the all these projects to be
achieved we've got to pick someone
winners
and the ones that we've done some work
on and can do some work on to see
achieved and we can't achieve that
without actually significant investment
from the crown it's the modelling's
showing that we just don't have that
resource here unless rates go up
substantially so that is taking a lot of
our staff time joanne i know is involved
in those
been involved in those conversations and
i have certainly appreciated
her wise guidance
through that
for me as i represent our council
in that space along with um jim
jim's support and knowledge as well
i'm really pleased by the way to see
that south brock's progressing the
working party is now about to go out and
your community members and business
members involved and we're talking about
the future of south brook it's looking
like the project for
the um the corner there will be uh
around the the lights um signalization
would be
uh
probably construction in later part of
this year but there's been a lot of work
going to that i really want to
acknowledge the staff who have been
doing a lot of planning to make sure
that we're in a really good position in
that space
just no
counselor williams
comments around writing can i just
really acknowledge the work of our team
through these events
i don't think
we you know there is a huge amount of
work that goes on and jared
joanne and others on those weather
events with our other staff carl and
they are actually
really out there trying to make sure
that our community is supported as best
as it can yes the wheat event has
brought about a lot of potholes and
certainly issues in our roads no two
ways about it but there's that's not
through a lack of commitment from our
team who i think are doing an absolutely
outstanding job trying to keep
you know
support our community through a pretty
tough time and it was these weather
events do represent a big challenge so
plus the contractors that were out there
there's been a lot of work going to that
and we're going to have a further
workshop around some of those other
challenges but just i'd like to place on
record my thanks to
jared
joanne and the team for their work in
that space i'm really proud of the work
that you do and
thanks for all that
you know in difficult times during
weekends and other things we're all
being stood up and out there just making
sure that we're responding as we need to
so thank you for all that work
thank you
so i've no no questions i have no urgent
uh general business
so i'll move from the chair that we go
into the public excluded are these
meetings live screened
they are so it's secondary councillor
blackie and we'll just wait for that to
i'll put it all those paper please say i
first i
against
carried and we'll just pause